[Musique]
nous l'avons tous remarqué le printemps
arrive et le printemps arrive aussi dans
les salles de cinéma donc dimanche 17
lundi 18 et mardi 19 mars 2019
les séances sont à 4 euros au grenier à
sel nous vous proposons la favorite
nous proposons aussi minuscule grâce à
dieu et weiss qui sont les quatre films
à l'affiché pendant le printemps du
cinéma
[Musique]
nous avons aussi un petit événement qui
aura lieu ce soir donc mercredi 13 mars
à 20 heures
c'est un débat sur le décrochage
scolaire
nous diffusons le film les grands
esprits le débat avant lieu après autre
information importante
il va y avoir prochainement des travaux
dans le cadre de l'enfouissement de la
nationale 10 et ils auront lieu autour
du grenier à sel le cinéma sera donc
difficilement accessible en journée il
ya en plus des nuisances donc
au jour d'aujourd'hui je connais pas
encore la date de démarrage des travaux
mais soyez prévenus que en journée il
n'y aura pas de séance publique
à part les séances commenceront donc
commenceront à 18 heures en semaine et
ont lieu toute la journée dans le week
end
[Musique]